هذه احدى الدورات الكثيره التي تنظمها
جمعيات محليه ودوليه في مدن مقاطعه من اجل
تاهيل متطوعين لدعم فرق مؤسسات الدوله
وللتخفيف من اللعب الكبير الذي يقع على
عاتقها
كي نفهم ما يحتاجونه من تدريب شاركنا في
عمليات اجلاء عده عملت معهم اسابيع كي
نحدد افضل طريقه للتدريب
رافقنا فريق متطوعين في مهمه لاجلاء عدد
من المدنيين من المناطق الخطره
استطاعوا الوصول الى هذا الرجل السبعيني
المريض في احدى قرى شرق قسطنطينه قرب خطوط
المواجهه في جبهه باخمود
لا يمكن للاشخاص الذين يعانون من ضعف في
الحركه المغادره بمفردهم وبقائهم هنا يعني
الموتى المحقق الامر خطير ولا ننجح دائما
في الوصول اليهم لكن نعمل كل ما في وسعنا
بمساعده الجيش تمكنت هذه العائله من
الابتعاد قليلا عن مناطق الاشتباك وفي هذا
المكان الامن نسبيا استطاعت ان تلتقي
بفريق المتطوعين
المحطه الاخيره كانت منزل رجل مسن اخر
ماتت زوجته التي كانت تعيله جيرانه ما
زالوا يرفضون مغادره قريتهم
يبدو ان استمرار جهود الاخلاء من المدن
القريبه من خط المواجهه يبقى افضل السبل
لحمايه ارواح المدنيين في جنون الحرب التي
لا تفرق بين بدني وعسكري ولا بين شجر او
حجر
عائلات تقطعت بها السبل واخرى فقدت معيلها
وعدد من المرضى وكبار السن هذه حصيله
عمليات الاجلاء لهذا اليوم ينتظرونا في
احد مراكز التجميع النازحين حافله تقلهم
نحو حياه جديده الى مستشفيات او ملاجئ في
مدن اوكرانيه اخرى يكملون ان تكون اكثر
امنا واستقرارا